ROGER MARTINEZ:
Today, we're talking
about Cloud Run, Cloud Logging,
and best practices for Compute
Engine.
I'm Roger Martinez, and welcome
to "This Week in Cloud,"
where we serve you
the lowest latency
news from the safety of home.
Cloud Run is now
integrated with Cloud Code,
making it easier to
develop with Cloud Run
by incorporating common
workflows with your IDE,
like creating new
Cloud Run services.
You can continue to
develop and debug
these services on
your local machine,
then deploy them with Cloud Run.
After that, once
they're running,
Cloud Code also helps you manage
and update those services.
Cloud Logging was
designed to help
developers and operators
easily identify the cause
infrastructure issues.
Since easy can always
be easier, we'll
keep working to
improve this service.
For example, we just launched
the beta for suggested queries,
which will recommend
logs that provide
context on your recent
error reporting groups,
learning incidents, and
other valuable logging data.
It's important to keep your
VMs up to date with OS patches,
but managing that
for large deployments
can quickly become a challenge.
While there isn't a magical
answer that works for everyone,
there are a number of best
practices that you can follow.
This list was based off of
patterns of other Google Cloud
customers with large
Compute Engine deployments
and includes ideas like
maintaining flexible deployment
groups and setting
a disruption budget.
The latest Google
Cloud whitepaper
is Cloud Key
Management Service Deep
Dive, which focuses on the inner
workings of Google's cloud key
management service platform and
the key management capabilities
that are currently available.
That's because we
believe that making
encryption key management
more performant, secure,
and compliant will
only be possible
if it's done transparently.
If you want to read more
about these announcements
or see a full list,
check out the link.
Any thoughts or ideas?
Leave us a comment or tweet us.
We'll see you in the Cloud.